une invention dans l'air du temps ce
petit boîtier circulaire ne passe pas
vraiment inaperçu
c'est justement le but à l'heure du
covic 19 et de la distanciation sociale
ils s'allument pour alerter son
propriétaire que les 1 m de rigueur pour
éviter toute contamination ne sont pas
respectées il s'agit d'un projet à la
mode est assez voyons qui nous
l'espérons attirera l'attention tout
d'abord sur la nécessité de garder une
distance sociale
l'appareil a été élaboré de façon à ce
qu'ils puissent être accrochées sur
n'importe quel vêtement
il peut également être porter autour du
cou lorsque la distance n'est pas
respectée ils émettent un signal
lumineux
puis il se met à vibrer si la personne
ne s'éloigne pas le principe de cet
appareil réside dans ses différents
types de signalisation signalisation
visuelle
lorsqu une diode électroluminescente
change de couleur en fonction de la
distance de quelqu'un devant vous il y a
aussi un moteur de vibrations qui fait
office de téléphone et vibre quand
quelqu'un approche de la distance
critique
cela encourage la personne a reculé à
augmenter la distance des pulls doté de
cette alarme pourrait être commercialisé
mais pour ses créateurs le but n'est pas
de les vendre à une quantité
industrielle
il s'agit plutôt d'éveiller les
consciences sur l'importance de la
distanciation physique
en cette période de pandémie